Among the things that I've learned over the years is that if Nathaniel thinks something's
cool or interesting there's reason for hesitation I'll just I'll just say it that way it's like, oh no
this is a great idea I'm gonna write a dissertation on on writing program administration, maybe not
that one was not good I know I'm gonna do a reading of the feed dress
that one's working out Paul George is the greatest player in the history, yeah yeah never
said that I'm just saying I think Nathaniel's an extremely smart guy I really do but his sort of taste
or just sort of his his intuition about the cool it's suspect
are you talking about these last two series? Is that what that's directed at?
that's the jumping off right right okay but there is a history
I like these last two series I mean it got me to read the first two series again
I think a good I think we should kind of focus on two things today I'm in a in addition to just
talking about the last two series but you know we should just kind of think about the the book as a
whole and I know one of the things that we were talking about in the one and then I think was the earth third episode that I'm editing right now
it's just that you know the organization the composition of the book and it's really the relationship between series and plateaus and you know we might have a different perspective of that
right now we're skipping the last you know four or so I I do think you know we don't need to spend a lot of time on this but it's worth just talking about why I mean even if that's just John saying psychoanalysis just I don't want to talk about shit and sex you know more than I need to you know in this way right right um but yeah I mean it does feel like a
it does feel like a concluding couple series here because he wraps it up with the central example through the Lewis Carroll stuff but yeah I mean it does feel like it does feel like a concluding couple series here because he wraps it up with the the central example through the Lewis Carroll stuff but yeah I mean it does feel like a concluding couple series here because he wraps it up with the central example through the Lewis Carroll stuff but
I do feel like the appendix though works more cleanly as a conceptual conclusion but these do feel like it's kind of wrapping up in a more traditional way like what like well like in a chapter kind of organization but I don't know I wasn't able to really key in to these last two series maybe as much as you were Nathaniel so I'm curious to see like what what gave you the the sort of ability to to key in here at the end
um two things yeah one I I liked the the penultimate series yeah when you know the the three esoteric words get kind of mapped on to the three kinds of series and the three parts of Alice's adventures and you know and that feels like a kind of concluding move to say like look there are you know the unpronounceable mono syllabism syllogisms there the portmanteau uh right yeah uh words and you
you know they're they're like they're like kind of correspond to the connective conjunctive and disjunctive series but you know at a certain point he's like but there's a whole story operating with if this is a kind of architecture there's a whole there are a whole series of stories happening within that kind of general architecture that kind of gets he gets at in in the the last series right
so there's there's there's that which you know did feel kind of satisfying as a conclusion the other one is I just I'm getting a clearer and clearer sense as to a delusian sense of of representation and I'm just increasingly bulking less at that that word that that word is just for me being appropriated into like the the notion of representation as sort of like the the the the a clear memetic reproduction
of some content is just at an instinctual level not working for me anymore it's not even like i
have to start with that and critique it and you know imagine some kind of a signifying thing
it's just increasingly becoming like obviously what else would re-presentation be other than
some kind of like how could the differential relationship between what is obviously two
dynamics not matter and why in the world would you ever think about that relationship exclusively in
terms of failure or obfuscation or you know opacity or something like that or clarity or accuracy or
any of the positive terms too right yeah yeah yeah that that you know it just increasingly seems to
me that representation just has nothing to do with with that kind of logic right yeah I don't need
to do conceptual labor to get myself there I I agree I agree with you and what I what I took out of and
I'll talk for a second in terms of my resistances but um I what I liked is the syntheses right the the
the three syntheses it made me think like wow I need to go back and reread anti-edipus because that's
where it's more the the three syntheses are more fully fully elaborated but in terms of thinking what's
the relationship among series how do they connect to one how do they insert themselves in and and this
being this sort of uh framework for doing so I I like that I mean that's appealing to me as like you said
as a kind of wrap up of the book here the different ways in which um so so I like that as well I also
like this stuff where he talked about uh psychoanalysis explicitly and just said you know there are bad
ways of doing psycho you know psychoanalyzing the author psychoanalyzing the work right um the the
bad ways of doing it so those resonated with me but the actual um I mean maybe I'm just too far
removed from the Alice in Wonderland stuff to really I did you know I read it so long ago you
know when we first started this that I don't really remember the chunks as well uh so the particular
reading um and I and I'll just say I mean for me that the issue with psychoanalysis is like
I don't know I mean for me it's like the equivalent of my relationship to horror movies which is
I believe and I know that there are very smart people who find things of deep interest in horror movies
I just don't and and never have like and I i turn on horror movies I'm like ah I don't want to watch
that uh just doesn't it's not just I mean I believe that there's I believe that I could learn I believe
that there's the possibility of uh really important stuff it just has never hooked me and never interested
me and my response is always I mean Nathaniel characterized at the beginning of like I don't
want to read about sex and shit and it's like it's kind of that simple yeah you know it's it's not a
sophisticated argument about why I mean at times I have tried to make it like why the analyses of the
psyche are sort of you know ineluctably subjective and consciousness oriented and all of those sorts of
Things I mean there are there are versions of psychoanalysis that are that are vulgar and
simplistic and are just kind of stupid which is not the ones that he's kind of using here but like you
know the ones where they're trying to find some ultimate meaning to the unconscious or your dream
where you're like decoding the dream and saying like well what does this mean in in the context of
your life and i find that kind of like meaning searching very just it's pointless i don't know
i i don't i don't understand it's it's all framed in that basic humanist uh you know system of thinking
this but this kind of psychoanalysis that he's running through i like you're saying i don't really
have the coordinates to to get a grasp on them like the oral and the anal i mean i understand the
differentiation and between speaking and eating i mean some of that is interesting but i'm like
i don't even really understand why this is that relevant for his system and why he wants to to write
through some of these uh like categorical divisions in order to give us his version of like difference and
becoming you know it's like i don't he doesn't seem to need psychoanalysis here in a lot of places
i don't even necessarily see the relation at some points well what i what i see
here when i when i'm reading the stuff especially on the Oedipus complex as i'm thinking of one in
several wolves and a thousand plateaus and and what i see him doing here is writing through a lot of
psycho psychoanalysis that is sort of based in like economic logics of lack of possession and emulation
and you know dispossession and you know i see him much more sort of with with a much finer with much more
dexterity he's sort of unlatching the dominance of those threads and those explanations from a more
general psychoanalytic terrain and what you know when he's talking about you know the the artist as
the the the diagnostician and it's like well you know these and when he's talking
about you know the relationship between states of affairs and bodies and language and the sort of
like the the sexual like sexualized threads or sexualized theories desexualized theories and then
resexualized like series like those seem to me to be much more contingent and multiple that like
yes you know these sorts of things happen they also don't happen and you know combinations happen in
this way or that way and you know the the critique that that he later along with Watery Levies against
Freud in One of Several Wolves is not an attack against edible uh development or act as development
there's an attack but that it's the explanatory mechanism yeah right where yeah you know this
is definitely a dynamic this is definitely a strata that one can get lodged on and and sort of like
develop out from but it's it's not it's not the baseline it's not right you know the the starting
point that that you're going to judge everything else from it's also it's kind of interesting to me that
he's not really critiquing Freud here and i i don't remember but does he like leverage a critique
against Freud in this book or is that for later that's for later i guess because he's sort of
complementary to Freud here he's like listen Freud's actually a good example of a psychoanalytic thinker
because he doesn't use it as an a priori um like theoretical framework to analyze phenomena he actually
builds the theory out of you know empirical data which i mean you know which i thought was like
because he later he's going to completely reverse that argument i would think right at least in in
terms of Anti-Oedipus and stuff well and so far as whatever he builds out of you know his his clinical
studies is becomes generalizable to the point where everything is that right i've always i i felt like a
a lot of the antagonism to psychoanalysis in the Deleuzian side is Guattari okay and it comes from
Guattari who was way more involved in right he was Lacan's psychoanalysis right right and and i mean you
know the the much more polemical dynamics that you read in Anti-Oedipus i mean i've always taken to be
Guattari's i mean my sense again i and i don't i don't know this because i don't know but my senses
in the in the 60s in France psychoanalysis is one of the edgy hip um intellectual discourses and i
don't mean that in a negative way i just mean like it was the the current sort of cutting edge of of
thinking and i think that's why he needs it right that's the reason why it becomes relevant and also
because i just imagine there's a i just imagine there's a ton of psychoanalytic readings of Lewis
Carroll yeah and Alice in Wonderland in the young girl right like it just sort of lends itself towards
you know certain types of of statements so i i it makes sense to me and i and i do see him
to to reiterate Nathaniel's point i i do see him doing what he does with the Stoics what he does with
with Kant what he does is like inhabiting him and twerking it uh and finding the cool stuff right like
The non-familial, uh, elements of psychoanalysis. So psychoanalysis is an analysis of desire, right? And
that's really interesting to him. Um, it just doesn't have to happen around the coordinates of mommy daddy.
Me, um, and that's a that's, uh, if anything that's a normalizing, like, that's the dangerous, uh, depth
laden way of approaching the thing. So I, I get why he does it. I get it makes sense to me, and I, and I,
actually believe that it would be more interesting but again it's like I wouldn't recommend that
somebody go read the Kafka book if they haven't read Kafka, you know, because it's just, it's just not
going to make any sense. He's going to be talking about all these, you know, animal short stories, and
you're just not going to know what they are. And, and I, that's how I feel when I read the Deleuze on
psychoanalysis is I just don't know enough. I, I get the point that he's inhabiting it and attempting to
do something with it. I get that but only very vaguely and distantly. I can't, I have no purchase on the
particulars because my understanding and experience with it is incredibly limited. Like I could teach an
intro class on Lacan or something, and I've certainly read Freud in my life, but I just don't really have
any sense beyond the most simplistic basis of right what you know, the the object ah is for instance
you know, right, the real, the imaginary, the symbolic, you know, like some of those baseline things. And he's
not dealing with those big, those big things. He's dealing with sort of particular strands of psychoanalysis, and I'm just too distant.
Mm-hmm. I mean, I do, I do like the idea that he, he at least runs with in a couple paragraphs where it's
like psychoanalysis is more about topology than it is about topical stuff, like you're saying it's not
about the mother or about these specific locales of psychical activity, it's about like different
dimensions intervening on each other. So like whether you want to call them the unconscious and the conscious
or whatever, it's about like dimensions of thinking and being interrupting each other and affecting
each other in ways that maybe you're not universal but are like kind of formal, uh, registers of, of
interaction or if you want to call it intra-action to borrow Barad's term. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Well, this makes
sense just within the big picture conversations that we've been having from the very beginning, is you
know what, why turn to psychoanalysis in a book that is you know effectively sort of focused on the
relationship between structure and event? And I mean what I essentially see him doing is rethinking
psychoanalysis, where the the sort of the structures that are relied on to create you know that that topological
map where you know this is the framework, this is the edible framework that we're going to work within
to reading those those structures as residues of different styles or different kinds of series
working on each other that don't have a predeterminate relationship with each other, that can
you know for this time, for you know this coordination, you know develop that, but it's only ever going to
then evolve elsewhere. Right. Yeah.
It reminded me a lot of uh Hegel's notion of concrete universality, and I was listening back to one of
those tapes too, and it's like when we when we tried to think through Hegel's notion of the universal it was
precisely through that, this kind of in this case Deleuzian register where every particular instance
instantiates the the formalism. So the the formalism or whatever the the framework uh is mutable and um
transforms alongside its context, so there's not just one overarching Oedipal framework that guides you
know human development. It's that each time it's a different Oedipal framework or whatever, you know. I I think
that's a really great way of for me that's a helpful way of thinking about it, like what you said in terms
of rethink. I mean, to me it's rethinking structuralism and and around series, right? That's that's the shift
is if you had structure and event you have series event right like and and that's the whole issue of the
surface uh throughout the book, and it seems to me that psychoanalysis is certainly at that time was a kind of
paradigmatic case of structuralism. I mean Lacan says as much, you know, that this is structuralism applied to
the the psyche uh structuralist linguistics even so Saussurean linguistics, and so it's an attempt to
you know inhabit it in order to kind of break up the the normalizing. I mean I can see why someone like
like Guattari would be interested in this this type of work insofar as he he had problems with the um
what I mean I, the normalizing function of psychoanalysis, so psychoanalysis as a certain dogmatism
right, and that I do think that that is you know I think maybe I was a little too nice in terms of
my problems with psychoanalysis in the horror movie thing is I do I have felt like there's something dangerous about it, like it is
it is a discourse of of normalization that has always felt like a policing. It's always read like
um you know and again not necessarily being handled in the the the work of very dexterous thoughtful
You know, folks, so that being said, um, yeah, because I'm not, I'm not reading widely in it, and I'm not
necessarily reading the best, you know, the smartest folks, but it has always felt to me like this is, this is how
things are supposed to work, right? Like the, I mean, the whole list from the neurotic to the paranoid and
the the distinctions among them. I get those distinctions, but there's always a sense of um
perversion is a problem, yeah, and and it is one of the things that I liken to lose is it's like
perversion in itself it's the case, you know, and I mean he's he says that in the chapters that we
read for today where it's it's immediately and directly perverse. It's not it's not that some of
them are, it's not like a particular instantiations end up perversions like no no perversion is truly the
case of of sexuality, yeah, and so that's that's more interesting to me. Still not enough to make me want to
get into it, um, well if you take uh if you take Lacan is like perhaps one of the best thinkers in that vein
I I take his the content of the arguments out. I think stylistically there's something a little off
uh with his writing. I mean, it's very domineering. You could relate it to Hegel
if you want, but this is but Butler's problem with Lacan seems to stem primarily with a stylistic
thing. It's like the way that he articulates these distinctions is itself authoritarian, um
it doesn't necessarily have to do with the content of the Oedipal framework. It's like the way he's
writing is there's something wrong there and it's a little bit if you if you find a passage on that
because that's that's the style question, right? Yeah, if you find a passage where Butler has said like
the the problem with Lacan is the disposition that one finds in the very writing not the categories
themselves, I would love I would love to check that out. Well, I might be kind of uh appropriating Butler
a little bit there. It might be tough to find that, but if it's yeah I mean I I might I might be able
to it's it's kind of I've been writing through because Žižek saves Lacan, you know, from Butler's
critique and I think they're both just wrong. It's like I don't think saving Lacan really gives
you anything, and I also don't think like Butler does try to do those kind of logical formal critiques
at times, and I think as like the problem with trying to do that with Hegel too is like it's really
difficult to like say oh he's wrong here. It's it it really is I think a a stylistic thing or a tonal
uh problem because Lacan is so smart clearly but it's like he's it's like he's toying he wants to be
smarter than you. He's toying with the reader. It's smartest guy in the room syndrome. Well right right
but it's it it feels it it feels um I don't even know what the word is exactly. It just it it feels
domineering, manipulative, manipulative, and it feels like he's having fun fucking with you like you know
and hey I mean there's room for those kind of people in the world. It's just uh I don't know if we should be
hailing Lacan as Žižek kind of tries to do you know it's as like the thinker you know it's like
Lacan Hegel for Žižek and I'm like I don't know I I never really understood the the need to save these
people. I understand the desire and the want to read them differently and to maybe offer a different
version a contingency you know version of Hegel or Lacan but but Žižek's compulsion to be like no
no they're actually like good or or ethical or the best. It's like I don't know I think Butler's
hesitance is spot on at times. Maybe the reading isn't perfect but and that and that might be a Žižek
thing as well because I I agree with you that's it that's a tonal or dispositional thing with Žižek
because he's never just going to say look I understand why that reading is out there there
are other readings that are available he's not going to do that kind of pluralism he's going to be like
those readings are wrong, right, this is the right one, and you're like dude and and I again dispositionally
that just always has rubbed me the wrong way. It's one of the things because Derrida will be like
playful and ludic at the reader's expense and that sort of stuff but it never feels like
at least to me or it doesn't often feel maybe it doesn't times but it doesn't feel like
Derrida thinks he's figured it out, right? You know, um, it's it's always like well we're trying
we're trying something and yes I'm a bit of a maestro in my efforts to try it because stylistically
I mean to me the the sort of ludic quality of some of the early Derrida and Lacan sound they sound
very very similar but I I agree with you there's a there's a a different tone to it and that's where
anything that you come across even if it doesn't say exactly that but if you come across moments of
you know whether Žižek saying it above saying I don't really care just things that I can point
to is like hey this question of disposition or uh orientation within the writing itself is is
objectionable or is laudable or is anything right is relevant is relevant so, you know, because I kind
of because kind of one of the underlying claims that I want to make is this is in fact what's been
driving the field of philosophy is this is resonance and dissonance of dispositions and styles not
development of thinking or right, you know, anything like that it's just it's dance moves off the top
of my head I think it's in their um, their joint book together where they really engage each other
on that level it's a hegemony contingency and universality it's like it's Butler Zizek and
Laclau and I just kind of ignore Laclau but uh I like the Butler and Zizek stuff but yeah I mean
there is I think a cruelty to Lacan's writing and by extension often in Zizek's writing which again
sometimes I don't mind I mean it's like Zizek can be mean to often to his uh interlocutors and I and
I think it is reductive a lot of the times that I'm like I guess that's just who he is I mean I
don't know a lot of it's smart and then he'll be like fuck you and then smart stuff and then a
fuck you it's like well you know and it can be funny I mean those things can be funny as well it
depends I mean it just depends and it depends of course on my disposition when I'm reading the things
and my relationship, you know uh so those the kind of you know I've got a whole chunk on voluptuous
vitriol um right like and this is the critiques it's critiques of Derrida I I don't know if you read
that or not but it's critiques of Derrida and they're like oh yeah they're extraordinary I mean
they are not it's not as simple as Derrida doesn't know anything it's like they go incredibly out of
their way in in in right very rich aesthetically uh provocative sentences to say Derrida's an idiot
doesn't know what he's talking about you know and it's like there's something in that act that I find
really kind of fascinating you know oh yeah and probably yeah probably symptomatic of something
as well yeah yeah they love to hate Derrida I mean they just love it yeah yeah and I get it and I
don't have a problem with that and I certainly I mean Derrida doesn't need me or anyone to defend you
know so no but yeah anything that you come across that sounds like that kind of shit send it my way
man because I I I'm always looking for because insofar as I want my claim to be not I've discovered
something because I don't think I've discovered something it's just I'm pointing to something that
has been a driving force that people don't ever talk about as a driving force right which is you know
because I I do increasingly think that it is it's like horror movies or it's like music it's like hey
I think that uh you know Jeff Tweedy is an incredibly talented musician I just don't really
like listening to Wilco right and and I don't understand and quite honestly I actually think that
that philosophy is the same thing yeah right it's it's not it's not because it's conceptual
and it involves thinking we we we try to treat it as if it's a different kind of thing and it's just
like eh you know it's got a good beat but I can't dance to it right that's really I mean that's the
underlying motif of the style thing is that's what drives like some things are going to hook you and
some things aren't it's true I like I like Avril Levine right which is why this is it's why I'm
I'm hesitant around like the tendency to save a figure who's been damaged by the tradition like
like I again I like Zizek's reading of Hegel a lot of it and I've used some of that to mobilize my
argument but the the entire project is this kind of uh savior of of like so Hegel's been
thrown to the side um or critiqued and dismantled and we wanted to get past him I'm going to save the
figure of Hegel and turn him into not just the best theoretical uh philosopher but also an ethical
figure and I'm like this is it's where it goes a little bit uh too far for me and he does the same
thing with the con it's one of the things that I had the most trouble with with Derrida on Nietzsche
because Derrida uh is very explicit in places where he's like I'm not going to save him from
uh the Nazi appropriation right and it took me a really long time I now find that to be a really
interesting decision on Derrida's part but for the longest time I'm like come on man like why not like
he clearly wasn't a Nazi what you know yeah um and so but but it is to your point of there's a
dispositional difference between you know like hey there are other Nietzsche's and and that's what Derrida
says I mean Derrida's line is there there is not I mean of all thinkers this is the one who gives
himself multiple names and get you know so uh there there are many Nietzsche's and I'm not going to say that
this one trumps that one or this one's better than that one this is just another one and and that that
sense of a kind of pluralism appeals to me more than it used to I I used to want him to smack down the the
Nazi uh appropriations but he would he didn't do it right right yeah I don't see the need to turn
someone into the answer you know for everything I I like this version but he's not the answer you
know because we know there's only one answer and it's fucking AI and I don't hear any arguments
I don't hear any arguments from anyone ever because only Alan Iverson yeah
Do we want to think about humor and its relationship to irony and satire? Yeah, I thought you I mean you
know Deleuze often runs this sort of irony verse humor things. This is one of the first times I've
seen him run the satire uh one as the kind of regression that I mean he doesn't use the
language but it seems totally caught up in the the sort of the schizophrenic movement of of
depth and pure paralyzing mixture right um right but the humor one was interesting like I can see
how the like good comedy doesn't have to be funny yeah just given the sort of the the descriptors
here you know like I know I'm starting with you know the third in the series but I'll just
read this quick part on on 248 in the in the last series it's like that's right at the end it's like
the literally the last paragraph of the book the university of sense grasps language in its complete
system as the total expressor of a unique expressed the event the values of humor are distinguished from
those of irony humor is the art of surfaces and of the complex relation between the two surfaces beginning
with one excessive uh uh uh well evocation humor constructs all university beginning with the
properly sexual advocate evocation which ends all of equivocity humor releases a desexualized
university a speculative university of being uh and language the entirety the entire secondary organization
in one word and then he just goes on to talk about like hey here's my here's my real someone I want
someone who's you know one-third stoic one-third zen and one-third Lewis Carroll right but that that
you know that there's a way in which humor and sense are incredibly tightly woven together as nothing more
than the communication between surfaces or between series right that you know sense as
um the particular weight and force and direction you know the singularity of of um of you know intersecting
series right that the the sort of movement displacement re-articulation representation that happens at that
moment that that is humor that's not an elevation that's not a regression that is a sort of transversal
movement that that forces you know a mutual transformation oh shit this you know these
two things intersect and now this is not that and that is not this and then sometimes it's really
fucking funny right right yeah I mean it's like it's another term for that ontological ethical
principle that runs throughout the entire book I mean you call it sense becoming humor in this case as a foil
for the um like romantic irony I think it it works very neatly here you know because the the romantic
sense of irony would be the kind of traditional um sense or from the position of a comedian where
they're in control of the entire apparatus the joke even if it's uh um self-deferential or whatever
um or what's the word not deferential but where you're making fun of yourself
what is what is that word um anyway that where
where yeah so you're even if you're making fun of yourself someone like Dave Chappelle is always in
control of the structure self-deprecating deprecating Jesus yeah self-deprecating um uh
that kind of humor it's always based on the unified subject you know if we want to use the kind of
theoretical terminology whereas Deleuze's humor is like you were saying transversal and kind of it
deconstructs the subject in a way where the it doesn't get to come back together at the end which
is sort of what happens in that traditional um romantic irony so I always I always think of it in
terms of distance was another way of saying what you're saying uh Nate um that irony to me presupposes
a distance that you're commenting on something even if that something is yourself right right like I I am
taking a position and reflecting on the fact that I am being a smart ass or whatever you know yeah um
or I'm that you're always exterior to the to the object right that you're talking about and I take that
humor and the commitment to surfaces to be I mean that's the sense in which humor again I mean I think
you said it Nathaniel it may or may not be funny but that's secondary you know that that what what makes it
humorous is the sort of um the the flatness of the the terrain from series series to series um not
its comedic quality right um but the the stuff towards the end I think is is quite is good but
it's very hard to to get a sense of yeah at least for me the the question of distance is what
distance from the object about which you're talking is what allows for irony to function
And that humor undoes, undoes that sense that there's something sincere, um, since here's the
wrong word though because that gives it a whole interiority of authenticity, right? Like, um, so it's
not sincerity is not right to me, it's also like a like a relinquishing of control of of some sort of
subjective control over the the situation, right? I mean the schizo invites that as well in some sense
right? I mean like there's no falls into the depths, right? And that's the key is like the satire which
you know, I mean like if if the ironist is always in control and always distances themselves from the
object of the the irony, even when it is themselves, yeah, there's always that that that level of control
and you know it's infinitely like the like the ironist can infinitely elevate themselves, right?
because they can then make an object of irony their own ironizing of themselves, right? Right?
Like, that's right, like the meta move, right? Yeah, exactly, it's the perpetual meta move, right? And
there's the community the show the show community is to me that's what it is and I totally enjoy that show
I love it, yeah, but it is 100 just Abed's character is the meta, I mean his character is
the meta move character in the show, you know, which gets meta moved, yeah, quite frequently. Oh, yeah, all
the time. It it it seems like humor and to lose in general is invested truly honestly invested in a
vulnerability that's like, yeah, constitutive, yeah, but now I'm just thinking of satires and like set I mean
like think about Colbert, Stephen Colbert and and John Stewart are satires not ironists although they do
definitely make ironic moves here and there but there's a reason why like especially for Colbert
um, you know, the more sort of like embodied physical humor matters more as
you know, yeah, you're when when like the ironist is always commenting on and it feels like the satirist is
always inhabiting. Yeah, the satirist but the problem with satires it's always at least to me it's always
a form of irony like you're inhabiting it in order to comment on it, you know, um, so that even as you're
assuming the role like Colbert is an example of this right now that commentary can be ambiguous
because people can hear it in any number of ways but but you were performing the persona of the conservative
Fox News host precisely to comment on it, to say how absurd ridiculous crazy nuts is this? Right? Yeah, it's
still like I mean can irony mobilize satire? I mean that would be kind of a question there. What do you
mean? What do you mean? Well can irony mobilize satire as a tool for commenting? Right? Does there need to be
like can there be an intermediate step there probably I mean I just feel like for to lose they both rely on
some sort of dialectical operation where there's the there's the true position like for satire, right? I
mean it's it's an easy uh opposition where you're inhabiting the bad position to make fun of it but there's
your true um ideology which is like behind that and that you would actually occupy in your personal life
or whatever, you know, and that's where that's why Colbert because you know the Colbert Report was one
show he's now right a different he's he's the liberal guy now I mean through and through he's the opposite of
what he what he was on the show, you know? Right now? Yeah, yeah, yeah, and I guess for to lose the the issue
is that it's not invested enough in that kind of constitutive complexity or or like dissociation that might
happen when you truly confront events
I used to joke about life being like a sitcom but the like is the word that's sort of gone away
and I've started thinking like no it just straight up is a sitcom like with all of the like um violence
and brutality that sitcoms can't can have often don't but um that it's not secondarily a sitcom it it
actually just is one, right? And with no viewers and and I think that slight shift from like to to
getting rid of you know from the what simile to the metaphor or whatever, um, is it's a different
perceptual experientially it feels very different not that that means anything but it's it does seem
like it when we talked about this a few weeks back I think of me coming me increasingly realizing how
influential television and movies and media are to how people walk around in the world and interact
with other people and that's what I mean so it's not just like well that's the artificial
and here's the real and it's been mediated through the artificial it's like no no no this stuff is
directly you know it's there's where the logic of mediation I think is is too dis too
distancing it's too ironic so you would have what you would have to do to that I mean the the the labor
that I would do to that that claim would be to take the supposedly transcendent features of the sitcom
which would include things like plot resolution yeah right and then flatten those out as as antigens on a
flatter plane which means that they aren't going to govern anything but they will provoke like those those
features right uh like you know those those supposedly governing features will not govern but that
doesn't mean they're not operative they will still operate in relationship to a whole set of other tropes
and uh that's that's interesting i mean do you have more like that's tell me more about that like what
it what it would mean for plot um to not to not govern um i mean so what happens like take you know the
life sitcom scenario that is deploying a certain you know array of of topoian tropes yeah and just one of
them so happens to be a resolution all right right right right so we're now it's now instead of thinking
about resolution as a determinant point within a plot where all of the you know all of the tropes and
topoi are going to now merge together in some harmonious unification harmonious unification
the force of a sense of of um um resolution is is going to operate within a set of of of uh other
tropes and topoi that some of also which operate within what something that we would call like a sitcom
yeah like like a sitcom environment other ones that that don't yeah i'm curious have either of you guys
watch this new um it's kevin can go fuck himself uh no the the girl from Schitt's Creek is the lead
and she plays the pretty sitcom wife married to the schlubby guy but the whole thing but apparently
she's like a serial killer or something like it's not funny it's really or rather i think it's kind of
did you guys ever see Natural Born Killers there's a chunk of Natural Born Killers where they shift into
sitcom mode and it's an ultra violent scene of brutality but it's all shot with a laugh track
and like a sitcom it's incredibly disjunctive Oliver Stone it's incredibly disjunctive and jarring and
that was 25 years ago um and i i take it i haven't watched it yet but i take it that this is something like
that it's it's clearly a commentary on the sitcom phenomena of Kevin James right like i mean specifically
right naming him for god's sake but i mean that sort of King of Queens that sort of you know the the beautiful
reasonable decent hard-working who's there to basically train a man child yeah you know uh um that it's
taking that but it's actually gets fun i mean i'm just sort of curious if that might be doing something
it's clearly interested in the structure of sitcoms it's about sitcoms right right well like let's go
back to Community for a second because i i definitely see the irony that is operative there and the meta
move on the meta move but those meta moves get out of control and not just i think because they go so
far up to just such rarefied air that it can't breathe anymore but they like there's a lot of sort of
like nomadic movement i think on that do you think i i wonder about that i mean i wonder about that
because i actually i went i did a whole Community thing during pandemic uh you know i re-watched it
and i i think it's a really smart and really interesting i really enjoy the show but i always
i mean especially towards the end i really got the feeling that they were pulling back on the abed
because of the transcendence function and they were substituting it with the main guy i can't remember
his name joe whatever is the actor and and he was the pragmatist who didn't have any time for the
meta move and it seemed to me like they were and i mean i i i see the idea of the the meta move becomes
not this way but you know this it becomes it becomes transversal and i'm like you have to get
into it a certain amount when because the move it looks like they're they're just purely going up but
when they start reaching back to previous episodes and especially when they reach back to previous
episodes that don't exist like in some of their like i think about the bottle episode that they do when
when when there's the lost pen and they're reflecting on all of the times that they've sort
of like gone through this exact same pattern and you know jeff is going to heal us and they like
flip back to a bunch of episodes that don't exist and they just do these little cuts right yeah little
cuts of things that you know like and a lot like they're setting the reader up to do this sort of
sitcom-y thing where you're going to like go back and reflect on you know previous episodes
because they do do that a lot i mean they do do do that but they splice it together with all these
other ones and sort of like you know the position of the of the viewer as the sort of like you know
like think about the situational irony of the or was it the dramatic irony or situation whichever one
like the viewer is aware of the disjunction but the characters are and they turn that on on the viewer
or like think about the claymation episode when you know the meta move is for abed to imagine his reality
as a christmas special but then the more transversal move is for um John Oliver John Oliver is sort of
smearing that pure meta move across two different plots at once right where like that meta move is
happening on the same plane as the as the regular right because what it's not is it's not like a
Special episode where it begins from beginning to end in um in claymation world they have a friend
who's how is going through a trauma and they like role play this whole claymation thing so it's
happening at two levels and then getting smeared across like other plot lines at the same time
i don't know because that that reads to me like the intrusion of the real into the hallucination there's
definitely that too um but it's but i i see i mean but the hallucination intrudes into the real
as well and not just for Ovid i think it would be really cool if we did this with like episodes
of shows like we actually you know we've read a lot of theory stuff now let's watch some like
watch the claymation show watch the Bo Burnham thing
i i like i like what i like what you said the way you articulated earlier i think was really good
where um i think of it as my yoga experience because about 10 years ago i tried doing yoga
and i remember when i went in the first time and it the the person who's leading it says like okay
everybody center yourself and i thought in my head i went oh fuck this yeah dumb ass version of centering
yourself and all right now i got to put up with this and whatever whatever and then the next
then several times later she says center yourself and i was like okay she doesn't really mean center
yourself she actually means de-center yourself that's actually what she's after she just is using this
dumb ass humanist terminology and then the third time by the very end of the summer i've been going to
this you know weekly or whatever and the third time she says center yourself and i just did
right it's like that that sort of of Hegelian progression from credit you know sort of criticism
to substitution to i don't even bother with criticism or substitution the way you're talking about
representation so you don't even need to go through the critique moves anymore when you hear
representation it just means something different than it meant and how could it not how could it
ever have not meant that like right and that's the point at least in my experience where you get into
trouble because now you start actually believing that everybody thinks representation is not uh
the sort of duplicative right uh relationship and so you say a representation because in your own
head it has a different resonance and everyone else is like what that's the bad guy that's been
yeah that's been my because i've always thought of it like especially through Derrida and his like
imploded version of of representation because it's really just repetition i mean like difference in
i mean representation repetition right right it's really just repetition and when you think of that
level of complexity i always loaded the term representation with that and so you just use
it as if it means that all right you do a little bit of explanation but like yeah again like most people
are thinking either like the platonic version of like the copy and the the model and the copy or
something that's where next week is really important but also by the way i just want to point out
when you say it's really just repetition think of the word repetition in the way most people hear
it it ain't the way you meant it no nothing's the way anything means differential repetition
and repetition of the same exactly are very that very different so i mean that's even in your
example it's like okay we can all say repetition yeah we don't mean repetition
right right right yeah well this is interesting to go back to irony and and humor and the sort of the
control of the subject versus the sort of like on control or the more much more like sort of like
imminently directed movements of of humor that are that don't have that that teleological track and i
went back and i read the first couple of of series and you know the very first one is about uh Plato
invites us to distinguish between two dimensions that have limited and measured things so let's call
that nouns and um or fixed quantities permanent or temporary which always presuppose pauses and rests
uh like john you call this uh picture thinking or camera like camera like where's like there you have
frames and they're all individuated snapshots of things but you can't think the movement between them
right you have to like go whole way from one to holy to something else and there's or you're thinking
about becoming in which case there are no pauses there are no rest there is no stable substance there
is only ever like a sort of internalized disequilibrium that is always you know mutating
that is always mutating and you know the the ironic move is always is is the move between those picture frames
right where it's like one one snapshot to another snapshot and there's the kind of control there
whereas like the the mad becoming is always just the sort of like the a differential repetition or a
differential movement between you know intersecting forces that you're that there is
yeah there's no there's no such thing as snapshotting that there is as you guys, it eludes the present
there is no, which like again like humor is not always funny. You can't control where it's going to go
you can't you can you could introduce resolution or the the coming back full circle or something like
that into those mad becomings, but it's not going to take on a teleological governing
operation yeah and and not just and not just on the perlocutionary level right like not just in terms of the effect that it has on an audience that they
either laugh right laugh. It's not just that; it's actually in the making of the thing yeah
yeah i mean it just points to also like the the move away from the kind of vulgar psychoanalytic
version of representation like not only for to lose is there a presence or it's not that there's a presence
that has been lost that we are aiming to represent represent it's that there has never was any presence
to be represented in the first place so it truly is just differential relations across this flat
ontological plane that you can't capture there's no capturing those those no question that terminology
doesn't even make sense in the system yeah that's where that's where i mean it feeds into that's where
the correctness failure thing it's like it just doesn't it doesn't have any purchase in the system
it's like that doesn't you know right or rather it's a secondary derivative way of freeze framing it to
make it look like that but i i that is the thing that has always appealed to me about to lose is it
seems i mean it's an ontological diagram that's so much more um i don't know diffuse or uh um
both precise and liberating or precise and yeah i mean yeah i mean it's it presents you with this sort
of limitless possibilities that always have to be enacted um but if nothing else you kind of recognize
or it allows me to recognize the really kind of deep normative ways in which all of my thinking is
structured right and and all of my actions and even the times when i think i'm being most free and most
liberated it's like no no no that's a very sort of constrained notion of freedom that thinks about
yourself as a self and etc etc and that's what i find incredibly compelling about to lose is that i
feel like it's going to infinitely push on levers that there's never going to be a point at which
it's like okay i got this this can't be right well if this makes the the dualism that he installs
between the physical and the metaphysical all the more interesting because you know it it
he does have a particular invested interest here in in language and and basically the way like
language logic the metaphysical realm the conceptual realm are all more or less the same thing for him
and they all interact with this other sort of like physical realm but these the relationship between the
two isn't one of that vulgar representation of one of commentate commenting and and mimicking and that you
you know this metaphysical series of operations invades and alters the physical and vice versa as as well as
that they're constantly you know intermingled with each other but you know like it's it's hard
it's it's hard to to to maintain the distinction between the physical and the metaphysical when
you make that move when it's when they're not of different kinds that's right when it's surely
connective convergent and divergent series that's it yeah right right um yeah i mean it is where i i i do
find thinkers like uh butler, hegel, even foucault sometime not necessary but uh like
like sort of productive to think alongside the lose because the lose is more emphatically a thinker of
potential and um you know of of dynamics whereas they that triad which is kind of difficult to
group them are much more thinkers of constraints and you know performative like uh dicta almost you know
so it's like i just find it um useful to think them alongside each other because i don't think one
i don't think either one is better than the other i just think i i tend to lean maybe obviously more
into the the lane of like what is constraining my uh my thinking or my being what's forcing me to to
act or or or think in these certain ways whereas the lose and i think you guys with the lose are more
invested in like how do we do different things you know as opposed to like sort of remaining at that
normative uh level of of behavior i i think it's the states of affairs slash actual versus right virtual
potential right you know as as as a mode of emphasis it certainly isn't either or right for for any of
those folks certainly not for butler no um but yeah i mean i i think that you're right i think that
there's there's a way in which for delus states of affairs are just kind of i don't know uninteresting
epiphenomena yeah not i mean that's that's a little bit extreme because states of affairs really matter
but they matter insofar as something is happening that makes them right not not them themselves
Uh, inessential, yeah yeah yeah yeah so I mean and again now I'm importing the sort of transcendence
model here which I don't want to do but right well he has the language of, yeah I mean here this this is
a good line for that, this is right after he's talking about sort of he's basically talking about a
physics of of sense and it's like or or of thinking of the movement from the nonsensical point to
the um the the mad becoming of the the line the the uh line moving in two directions that winds to
the sort of the production of the surface the plane so you know be uh the uh it is this whole system
point line surface that represents the organization of sense and nonsense sense occurs to states of
affairs and insists in propositions varying its pure univocal infinitive according to the series and
states of affairs which it sublimates and from which it results and the series of propositions from
which it symbolizes and makes possible um the the way that like it in some ways it's like states of
affairs would be all too uninteresting all too dumb of an animal to to you know parody that Nietzsche phrase
uh without without without um the sense that insists yeah a sense that insists that that sort of puts
them in it would be all too schizophrenic I would put it this way states of affairs would be all too
schizophrenic it would be all sort of like a downward regressive movement of of bodies mixing and settling and
uh without a kind of uh conceptual lightness to bring it all up to the surface and allow
for states of affairs to communicate with each other in ways that they wouldn't otherwise be able to
communicate or without which we would call perversions right yeah yeah yeah I like that yeah
let me also say since we're wrapping up now how much I've missed you guys and how much I've missed
this like seriously in the last three weeks I've been jonesing and so this is I mean this is great yeah
it's been a while it's been a minute since we had a podcast
Thank you.